indigènes se dit d'une espèce végétale
présente naturellement sur plusieurs
territoires depuis des milliers d'années
sans aucune intervention humaine
c'est le cas à la réunion du film terre
une arme rampante qui pousse
principalement sur les parcelles
agricoles reconnaissable par ses petites
fleurs roses tout allonger cette plante
est riche de vertus médicinales
fumeterre qui plante aussi très utile
dans la petite anne c'est dans les eaux
assez en altitude quand même près de 600
700 mètres trouve ali facilement un
quart de l'année
en ce moment il trouve ali et commentera
un peu sur la fin prend place mais lille
et pousse les poussent en abondance
quand il pose à quoi les poussent en
abondance le film pearl est connu pour
ses utilisations nous a fait débat pour
des problèmes de peau quand de mounana
l'eczéma camp de mounana problème la
gale quand de mounana problèmes de peau
en général le film toy ils remettent
bien tout ça et fume c'est à dominique
sonné
son principe amer en mer dont le fiel
donc pour soigner tout ce qui est la
bile de fois je fume terre très très
bonne tisane en association ou bien tout
seul pour le foie mais ne pas dépasser
trois jours à ne pas prendre non plus
parce qu'il peut y avoir des risques de
problèmes de aux yeux si on en abuse
donc le film tn petite dose type de film
terre par exemple aux comme ça pour
trois verres en infusion va pas faire en
décoction fumeterre offert en infusion
s'alliant faire faire bouillir de l'eau
et versez l'eau bouillie sur un petit
peu comme ça on l'a s'infuser 20 minutes
la 25 minute
ensuite on boit un verre matin midi à
metz
à 4 heures c'est dire donc pas plus de
trois jours après le super
dans une coopération décoction là nous
va prendre frotte que les la nouvelle
noire et dans cette bouilloire en même
temps nous va mettre des plantes
décoction deux ans la ville par exemple
désormais vide et fumeterre un dans ma
ville et pas que l'aco l'avait lanouf et
peu de plantes comme ça pour à peu près
un litre et demi un litre un litre et
demi
bon il me l'a s'est dit bien décoction
pour le bas litres un litre et demi ne
peut rajouter un peu trop prudente
regarde bien boxée box est au top
mike ce n'est pas propre pour que ces
pays pauvres qui touchent à dakar au
corps mais pas dans n'importe quel cas
on compte parce qu'elle est un poison
par les producteurs donc veillez bien à
ne pas ramasser n'importe rouge le
portent pas très bon pour le psoriasis
très bon pour les problèmes de peau
lanouf un petit peu par ici on ne peut
rajouter là dans d'autres clubs mais là
c'est pour montrer comment nous fait une
décoction donc nous a versé l'eau de la
berceuse dans l'eau est froide ne batte
les plans dedans nous recouvre la
casserole le voir comment ça se fait
dans une grande marmite dans une
casserole ne fait ça pour 5 10 litres là
c'est démonstration de chauffe nous
laisse de l'eau bouillie un décoction
dans cinq 5 minutes 10 minutes
mais bon c'est sûr que ont pas en bise
et c'est pour salade aux minimes
on va prendre ça sur trois jours pas
plus de trois jours parce que on va
sentir dès faiblissement niveau des yeux
la vie va peut-être baisser si on abuse
à prendre en une semaine deux semaines
trois semaines c'est vraiment pas tisane
à prendre là selon terme sais c'est que
c'est une salle des propriétés pour
bouffer les graisses c'est bon pour les
cholestérol c'est bon pour les problèmes
de perte de
quilibre âge de poids mais vraiment ne
pas en abuser comme d'autres plantes
temps pareil c'est la dose qui fait le
poison et la dose qui la surdose qui
pourrait faire du mal
personnes qui ont un avis